we don't need to rely on historical and
cultural forces to live a good life more
ancient more powerful deeper forces are
at work that have been shaping us for
goodness for a much longer time boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don shotgun super excited
to be talking about our blueprint for
goodness we have dr. Nicholas Christakis
joining us on the show hello thanks for
having me so so honored that you decided
to join us on the show this has been
such a good synthesis your latest book
blueprint the evolutionary origins of a
good society and just recently released
and we'll be talking about that a lot on
the show for those that don't know
Nicholas is background he's a
sociologist and physician known for his
research on social networks and on the
socio-economic bio social and
evolutionary determinants of behavior
health and longevity he is a sterling
professor of social and natural science
at Yale University where he directs the
human nature lab he's also the
co-director of the Yale Institute for
Network science and you can find all the
links in the bio to his profile there
Yale as well as the human nature lab as
well as his Twitter profile in the link
to his recent book
all right Nicholas let's start things
off with one of our favorite questions
to ask our guests what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world well I
mean that's like over home plate I mean
that's what the book is about you know
that's not a hard question I think I
think when when I think for far too long
in my view scientists and the person on
the street have been far too obsessed
with the dark part of our nature our
propensity to violence and selfishness
and mendacity and tribalism but I think
the bright side has been denied the
attention it deserves because equally we
are prone to be good we are prone to
have these wonderful capacities for love
and friendship and cooperation and
teaching and I would argue these
qualities are more prominent more
powerful more forceful in us then then
the dark side and the reason is that if
whenever I came near you you um you were
mean to me or or killed me or mistreated
me in some way I would have been better
off as an animal being you know apart
from you we would have evolved to be
solitary animals so the very fact that
we live socially in the way that we do
suggests that the benefits of a
connected life must have outweighed the
costs and so the argument my argument
would be that over the long sweep of our
evolutionary history over three hundred
thousand years we have been shaped by
natural selection to be endowed with
these wonderful qualities that these
qualities are extremely powerful that
they are more powerful than the evil
qualities and furthermore that because
we've been endowed with those qualities
by natural selection they are universal
they are seen in every human being and
in every society around the world and
furthermore in contrast for example to
Steven Pinker's arguments about the
progress that human beings have made
over the last 200 years because of the
philosophical movements and
technological advances of the
Enlightenment beginning since the
Enlightenment which no doubt have
redirected human trajectory in the
trajectory of our world to be better
we're safer we live longer we are
healthier we have more technology with
more democracy more peace he's no doubt
right about all of that but those forces
are acting over him over historical
timeframes and what I'm arguing is is
that we don't just we don't need to rely
on historical and cultural forces to
live a good life more ancient more
powerful deeper forces are at work that
have been shaping us for goodness for a
much longer time so that's my answer to
your question which I you know I'm glad
to see you're asking
there's something that's so deep in our
human nature this desire to collaborate
this desire for friendship this desire
to co-create a positive beautiful future
together to ensure peace between each
other all of these are so deeply rooted
in us and since the dawn of time and I
like how you take a lot of time goes
quite a far yeah none of our species
lies yes it could and it could
potentially even go to the dawn of time
with the way of all the other evolution
of the species that they also have this
is a deep essence
no because species no other species
don't live socially I mean I think that
we are different than than the
transmission of knowledge things like
that solitary lives we are we are
different than than many insects we are
different than than octopuses we're
different than than the reptiles and and
fish so you know we we live socially in
a very particular way and one of the
things that I show in the book and that
I argue and that is sort of paradoxical
is that if you the more we study certain
other social mammals the deeper
understanding we have about ourselves
and here's why as an example if you go
and you map the social networks of
elephants like the the the mathematical
structure of elephant networks will
actually let me back up just from that
for a moment so it's very common many
species reproduce sexually many species
have sex with each other but we do
something else we form long term non
reproductive unions to other members of
our species namely we have friends and
this is very rare in the animal kingdom
we do it certain other primates do it
elephants both Asian and African
elephants do it and certain cetaceans do
it certain whale species so this is an
unusual feature that we evolved to have
this what countries say that a school of
Pera not friends with each other for a
long-term non-reproductive unions two
unrelated individuals so those fish
might be related to each other they
might be a transient interaction like a
herd of buffalo moving on a plane it's
not like I'm next to you as a buffalo
and we're always together you and I
that's a different kind of sociality a
different kind of social process so I'm
specifically talking about friendship
okay and so we do it in so do elephants
and what's really interesting is is that
elephants and then as a result of these
friendship connections we form social
networks with very particular
mathematical properties so like if you
map these networks and look at
mathematical structures of these
networks are very specific and in fact
in some work we've done in my lab we've
we've sent people around the world we
have map networks in Tanzania and Uganda
and the Sudan and India and Honduras and
in places around the United States and
again and again the structure of the
networks is the same it's sort of
universal which is part of the point I'm
making which I thought you have a
certain amount of like close friends and
these like these third-degree
connections where you can spread your
that's another whole yeah but for now
it's just that they like the the the the
structure of the network the dots and
the lines that connect them yeah you can
summarize that in various mathematical
ways is very similar around the world
anyway if you go on your map networks in
elephants you find that the elephants
have friends and their networks look
like our networks which is astonishing
because the last common ancestor we had
with elephants was 85 million years ago
that animal did not live socially and so
the elephants by independent convergent
evolution have fixated on the same type
of social process that we have they have
friendships they didn't need to have
friendships they make networks that look
like our networks that need them in the
case but here's the punchline the deep
irony here is is that by looking at the
similarity between us and elephants we
can come to make the following argument
if we can share the capacity for
friendship with elephants we can share
it with each other
the universality of this quality in us
is proven in a way by its coexistence in
this animal species yes and furthermore
if you if you if you do anthropological
investigations and you go around the
world and you look for societies and you
try to quantify is there a society
without friendship the answer is no so
this is a deep and universal property
within human beings and we must we must
have friends and we must have them in
order to be able to live socially it's a
it's a part of our nature yes and even
the nature of other species that yes
again study will you show us on a
network graph show us what it would look
like if you were the center node and
then you had the similarities across
species that we as a center node have
connections these spokes to other nodes
that are then are let's say our friends
and then they have their friends and so
on their friends so on the book there
are pictures of elephant networks and if
you look at the pictures of elephant
networks and you look at the picture of
human network so you look at the picture
of whale networks side by side they're
very they're indistinguishable you know
you could see a picture of a human
network there these dots and the lines
every dot is a person and every line
between them represents a relationship
between two people whose whose friend or
whose sibling or whose mate for example
and these these these dots and lines
will form an intricate pattern that has
a center and a periphery and there'll be
the social periphery people have
relatively fewer friends and whose
friends have fewer friends and in a
social Center people who have relatively
more friends and whose friends tend to
have more friends and so you can map
this graph and in your mind's eye you
can also invoke a kind of metaphor of
which is not exactly right but at least
you get a sense of it like a tangle of
Christmas tree lights where every bulb
is a person and then the wires represent
the connections and you can imagine this
dense commish of Christmas tree lights
when you take them out after a year in a
box and you try to loosen them up by
pulling out the tendrils of the
Christmas tree lights and then they kind
of spread out in front of you and and
then you can look at you can do a
similar process where you map networks
of other species as like elephants and
whales and they will look similar
another way to cultivate if the keynotes
have lots of connections of their nodes
may not have a lot of connections but
it's not just that it's that the whole
structure it's like saying you know I
could take a group of building materials
and I can build a house and and the
house is basically the same house you
could take the same materials and build
houses would that look different but the
house that we built is very similar to
the hut with the same materials as the
house that an elephant will build or
another way to cultivate an intuition
about networks is to imagine you have a
hundred buttons like collect from a
shirt and they have let's say four holes
which is is a simplification let's say
each button has more holes and you screw
the buttons on the floor and I give you
five hundred pieces of string and I say
you're gonna pick two buttons at random
and connect them yeah yeah that's okay
and then you're gonna use the next piece
of string or the next piece of string
Wyden's gonna have a more of there's
gonna be a power log yes exactly yeah
yeah so by chance you should have the
intuition that some buttons might not
have been picked at all they'll have no
friends
they'll have no connections and other
buttons might have been picked a lot of
times and so that's the first
realization that that there will be this
jumble of strings and connections and
buttons people are the buttons the
strings are the relationships and you
should have the recognition that if you
look at you could look at them down now
on the floor and take a photograph of
that mess and and and then you could
lean over and pick up one of the buttons
and pull it up into the air and if you
did that you should have the intuition
that all the other buttons that were
connected to that would come up but what
all the buttons come off the floor only
like 30 or so well yeah of a lecture
yeah that's pretty good your guests
actually probably more like 60 but not
all of them it's very good that's a
pretty sixty out of the hundred by
chance will have been picked yes well
because they only have at least one
fresh
yeah so some of them so sponge they'll
come up and then the other ones that
were never picked they'll be
disconnected they'll have their other
sort of networks over there yeah and
then you can take this little thing and
you should have a sense that they'll be
this person here and then one string
removed from em will be all the people
that are one degree of separation and
then another layer of buttons two
strings removed yeah all the people that
are two degrees of separation from them
and so forth and then you should have
the intuition that if you take this
this jumble and drop it over there and
photograph it again the two photographs
of the two jumbles will look different
and yet you should have the intuition
that even though the photographs look
different there's something deep and
fundamental which is hasn't changed at
all that's the particular or arrangement
of the buttons with respect to each
other that's known as the topology of
the network the structure of a network
the architecture of a network anyway
that that type of structure there's
certain mathematical ways of describing
it are seen around the world in in all
societies and also in elephants and
whales and certain other primates so
that means there's something very deep
and fundamental about that particular
kind of structure to us and and it's
inescapable it's innate it's natural and
good I would argue Wow
so you there are mathematical properties
about the way that our species organizes
with an are you seeing it as a as a
topology yes I like that it's the
topology of the topological
representation of how our networks so
the idea is then that other species have
different topologies that they organ no
other species are the same ones as else
in elephants you said but then under
primate well no primates but you also
gave us indications that octopi or all
these other yeah they're different they
don't have friendships see that's what's
interesting is that so certain the kind
of other ways of living socially yeah
yeah like you social insects so termites
and wasps and so forth but in ants but
the thing about those insects is that
they're clones they're genetically
identical they don't actually need
friendship in order to be social they
just are nice - it's like being nice to
yourself if you're an ant all they
answer they're genetically identical all
in the incident colony that's what it's
like yes yes I use that Wow
so really what if it would just be a
bunch of clones like yeah we're talking
like millions of clones it's like just
yell in the Nemesis building an ant
structure so then why would you need to
interact with the same perp yeah why
would you need to be why would you need
a single I'll be nice to you and not him
you're all the same we're all we're all
siblings we're all identical siblings
so so the ants have a different set of
problems and they're very instructive in
understanding the origins of sociality
but they're different than us the ants
are different than us and they're also
different than animals that for example
that the packs of wolves which often are
very closely genetically related they'll
be the offspring of one sort of let's
say depends on the species one
particular male or female going back one
or two generations so they're like
cousins or siblings to each other those
are all interesting and there's also we
talked about schools of fish and herds
of cattle and they have all kinds of
other social properties too but all of
those are incredibly interesting and we
can learn a lot from them but they are
different than then our problem which is
how do we organize our relationships
with people who are unrelated to us how
do we how do we avoid killing each other
when there's no genetic reason to avoid
killing each other and so we have
evolved a set of capacities to do that
and so then the idea would be that if we
were to run another simulation of the
evolution of yes land at Earth that we
would see a very similar yeah apology
yes how we organize yes and that's and
that sort of thing with the elephants so
the elephants ran that experiment for us
and they have all of these qualities
like they have friendship they have
cooperation they have in-group bias they
have smiled hierarchy they have identity
now this is a very interesting idea so
you take it for granted that you have a
unique identity as a person and and that
everyone does and that you can look out
at a sea of people and every one of them
has a unique face and you can that's how
we signal our identity in our species we
use our faces but why I mean it's it's
it's an evolutionary luxury that we are
able to have variable faces why don't we
all have the same face you know like
there's a little bit complicated there
but yes we're like penguins or cows or
something you know we look at it each
other and so it turns out the regions of
our genome that are responsible for
forum making our faces are very variable
and
deliberately so so that we each have a
different face that we can use to signal
this is me not someone else and the
reason we do that is so that our many
reasons so that our parents feed us and
not strange kids they can see oh that's
my good thing they we also want you to
sell that's my friend not my enemy I
need to be able to tell apart my friends
are yes
so furthermore not only do we have this
this evolutionary luxury of signaling
our identity using our faces but we also
have this evolutionary luxury of being
able to detect the difference like a big
part of your brain is devoted to being
able to tell the difference in other
people's faces yeah so all of this is
very expensive why do we do that well we
do that in order to be able to live
socially do they be able to remember
who's a cooperator and who's not who's
our friend and who's not who's our
partner and who's not if you didn't care
about who you had sex with you would
need to be able to tell the difference
but you do care about who you have sex
with so you need to be able to tell one
person from another for instance and
amazingly elephants do this and whales
do this by independent evolution
elephants have evolved the capacity to
signal who they are and to recognize
each other as individuals so these these
qualities of identity friendship
cooperation and so forth teaching which
we may come to later yeah all of these
qualities are very wonderful special
qualities that we have that natural
selection is equipped us with and that
are crucial to us being able to live
together and make a good life whoa
Nicholas is so interesting learning from
you about the and the variability in our
genome for the way that are a unique
identifier a face evolved so that we can
more easily then for the mother to be
like oh this is my child to feed or for
know to know friend to friend yes or no
so for example there's even differences
between this regard between rats and and
sheep so for example rats can't tell
their pups apart so you could take the
rat pups from a mother's little group of
rat pups swap out someone else's rat
pups and she'll feed them she can't tell
the difference the reason is that rats
have evolved the capacity to detect
places rather than individuals so they
feed the rat
in this area why because when their pups
are born they're immobile so there's no
need to know one pot this is this is
this pup and this is this pup and
they're mine and that's that pup and
that's not mine
no the rat pups can't move so the rat
mothers just learn this is where my pups
are in this location I'll feed the pups
here so sneaky scientists can swap them
around but sheep as soon as a sheep is
born it has to be able to move otherwise
it would be prayed the ancestral sheep
would have been eaten the immobile
ancestral sheep so sheep from the moment
they're born they can move so in a big
herd how do mothers tell their offspring
so that they feed their offspring and
not someone else's offspring they have
evolved as they use scent so they can
signal sent by scent biology is so yeah
Ellucian Airy dynamics are so cool yes
yeah there's so much cool stuff like
that when you spend decades studying it
and finding these unique insights is
sharing them with people so that we gain
a better understanding of not only our
own true these deep laws of our own
human nature but also how other species
have evolved and yes and all these
different mechanisms like scent and when
is describing nicolas explain to us what
we should do about the power law and
dynamic that's evolved within our
network topology because if this button
string has 60 buttons on it yeah and all
these poor buttons over here have only
by themselves or a couple of others
there will be a second cluster so
they'll be like let's there a string a
30 look yeah yeah a second string of
like 20 and then and then the remaining
10 or whatever will be I on their own or
couplets or something I don't know the
precise distribution but that's
approximately right it's a little bit a
little bit more complicated because in
my example every button had four holes
in your variable holes anyway now the
parallel thing is what you're alluding
to is is that people vary in how many
friends they have
and learn how much wealth they have
accumulate is that there's another power
loss that's a nothing so now what do we
do about these in equal distribution of
friends I think well so friends the
distribution is not as unequal as you
would think we've looked at this okay so
on average people have about 4.5
individuals of them they're socially
intimate you can ask questions like who
do you discuss important matters or
personal matters with or you might say
your spouse and your sibling and your
best friend and another best friend or
who do you spend your free time with we
might ask you or we might say I'm gonna
give you we've done this I'm gonna give
you something of value that you have to
give to someone else you can't keep who
would you give it to so I could use that
heuristic to take session yeah yeah so
if you use that heuristic to see who
would you be anonymously generous to
right so we've done that for instance
we've used up amongst the hot Sun
hunter-gatherers of Tanzania we they
love honey and and in order to get honey
they have to do these risky things where
they climb up trees they don't have any
protective equipment actually they have
a they have a honey I forgot what it's
called it's like a honey find your bird
there's like that it's one of the rare
examples of a human animal pairing in
nature a symbiosis with our species
where these honey birds will identify
where the beehives are and then the
hodza will climb up and knock the
Beehive down getting stung they'll take
most of the honey but they'll leave
behind some of the some of the UH the
what does it call the honey to comb the
honey and the birds eat that after they
got the humans to knock it down anyway
the hodza love honey but it's a real
pain for them to get it we just went to
Costco and bought honey sticks so we
took these honey sticks to Holland to in
Tanzania and we gave the hodza
respondents the honey sticks and we said
you can't keep them who would you give
them to interesting and we map the
networks of the Hodja that way any way
you can map these networks using
different sorts of techniques and when
you do that around the world you find
that about two to five percent of people
have no one when you ask the believe you
spend free time with their we begin to
discuss important matters in two to five
percent say NOLA inside in our society
to you have those approximately that
aren't there they might be isolated
widows or they might be people who never
made friends or had other problems for
example and at the upper end of the
distribution you might have two to five
percent or so I don't remember the
precise numbers who have eight people or
more but the great majority of people
have in that range and the average is
about four and a half okay people so so
it's so it's it's pretty tight but there
are when it comes to actual friendships
real relationships when you look at
other sorts of things like phone calls
or Facebook friendships or Twitter
followers then you get a more power law
distribution or some people you know
like the Kardashians or something might
have millions of followers and the rest
of us just have ten thousand or ten
followers or something and then what do
you think we can do about the inequality
in power law distributions for wealth or
for well that's it yeah a tough one
well that's a different topic I mean I
think that
some inequality is a state of nature
people are porn with different talents
it's called the natural lottery some
people are born very tall and others
very short some people very fast and
others very slow and some people weren't
very smart and there's not so smart and
this just is just a play of chance you
know now some of that is sometimes due
to the environment if your mother was
starving when you were in utero
this will hamper your own life prospects
birth or I should stress by that example
I should stress that by born I don't
just mean in doubt genetically you can
be you can be born to a poor parent for
example or you your birth order or your
mother could have had an infection while
she was pregnant with you so there are
other kind of phenomena in the
environment that can affect your life
chances at birth so but I say the
natural lottery that's what I mean I
mean things you didn't do things that
just you were gifted at birth this was
your life or whether you're born in in
Greece or in South Dakota for example
you know just you know just that's what
happens you know that's just your lot
you know that's the natural audience so
some of that is son of that inequality
that we see in our species is also seen
in other species other primate species
and is irreducible and there may even be
reasons for it but that's different than
the social lottery the social artery is
then what the society do to you after
you're born and argue in a society which
for example exacerbates the natural
inequality or compensates morning so
here's an example let's say some people
are born blind and some are not blind
that's a working of the natural lottery
but then what does the social lottery do
does it build a society in which we have
Braille books and and auditory you know
audible stoplights and and elevators and
do we compensate for the natural lottery
in a beneficial way reducing the
inequality or rebuild the
neuroprosthetic yes or we do other
technologies or or do we invest money
and restoring sight to people who are
born blind and that's possible in the
distant future or do we build a society
that exacerbates it is sort of you know
is sort of every man for himself kind of
society which the now of a sudden
why is the gap between the sighted and
unsighted so so the social lottery is
different than the natural lottery so in
a way we could think about it like or
when we see the power law of that of
wealth that inequality that's occurring
are we seeing the people that are
finding themselves at this very end of
having so much of a surplus of wealth do
we see them building things
incrementally that help themselves
become more wealthy or do we see them
building the things that compensate for
the wealth inequality to where people at
the lower end of the distribution have
more degrees of freedom and more
opportunities for them to pursue their
own northstar and creative endeavor in
these types of things yes yes way to
view it yes and it's not just the people
at the top but it could also be the
state state actors I mean are you in a
state that attempts to for example
redistribute wealth or or not and or
grow wealth in certain ways that are
beneficial to the bottom or grow wealth
and certain ways that are not beneficial
to the bottom etc now some we have done
some experiments looking there's
something called the Gini coefficient
they're just a measure of inequality it
goes from zero to one zero is perfect
equality everyone has the same one is
perfect inequality one person has all
the wealth and everyone else has nothing
and typically the ginnis range from
let's say 0 to about 0.4 would be
American or Moroccan level of inequality
and 0.2 would be sort of Scandinavian
level of inequality when people have
gone to hunter-gatherer societies that
live as we did in the ancestral way
forager societies and as people tend to
have very few possessions often because
they have two very mobile so there's not
a lot of stuff they can take with them
and they also don't have a farm or
or cattle you know they don't have
domesticated animals so they're very few
markers of wealth at all but even in
them there is some inequality in terms
of their assets so Daddy study the
burial grounds and things like that or
the good someone has a big bow and arrow
and someone doesn't someone isn't an
arrow someone is eight etc so they've
their inequality their Gini is about
0.12 for instance but even in those
societies you know if you interview them
and you say well who's a good hunter
they'll say he's a good hunter and he's
not natural lottery or social lottery
your father taught you to be the hunter
his father did not teach any be a good
hunter so there's always some variation
and in fact in blueprint I talked a
little bit about how mild hierarchy or
moderate egalitarianism is also a
necessary part of a well-functioning
society societies that are absolutely
equal tend not to function well they're
very chaotic someone's good at one skill
and they are great to then go and teach
other people that skill and then I pick
up a different skill and I help them
with that skill that I know and they
help me with the skill that they know
and we form into the hierarchies of
competence that then help us do specific
attributes that make the func the
civilization function well with all of
its unique components because we're all
uniquely equipped in those competence
hierarchy right so you're exactly right
there could be that type of
complementarity and there have been some
arguments about how variation in human
beings you know you're strong and I'm
smart or you can see and I can you know
row right so on the you know on the
Argonauts you know Jason famously had
one guy who could see very far he had
fantastic vision you don't need all ten
of the sailors to see far just one is
enough to see where the shore is the
rest have to be able to row and you need
one guy who can navigate by the stars
right and so forth so you can form
groups or for example ancestrally you
could have some people who are very good
at locating prey and other people who
are very good at like spearing the prey
let's say so you're talking about
complementarity but it doesn't just need
to be that way because sometimes
exceptional individual can generate
benefits for people around them even
without any complementarity so for
example a simple example of this might
be someone who can who knows how to make
a fire so we're all ten of us in a group
we're cold one guy makes a fire for
himself even selfishly but then we all
benefit from the fire right we can all
warm ourselves by the same fire so there
we don't even need to give him anything
he's happy to do that he makes a fire
just for himself but he creates what's
called an externality now and that the
rest of us can benefit from so anyway
there many advantages getting socially
yeah okay okay I like that one all right
I want to see so so much of a blueprint
and so much of what now the study of
indigenous cultures are more deeply
around the planet is showing to us which
is that we come from this same origin we
come from the same source I'm curious
what your thoughts are on us all coming
from a same source or a same origin and
what that can do to unite our species
because you look back you're like who is
your parents their parents their parents
my parents my parents my parents and you
just keep going back and it's the
evolution of life in the first place and
so well there's a lot of discoveries
right now in physical anthropology the
origin of our species keeps getting
pushed back so even 30 years ago it was
thought that homo sapiens sapiens our
particular species was fifty thousand
years old but now people believe that
anatomically modern humans have been
around for about three hundred thousand
years and a lot of the new genetics that
is being done on undiscovered bone
fragments shows that we we still spread
out of africa but there were probably
multiple migrations and more importantly
we interbred with Neanderthals and Homo
florensis and other other hominids that
had preceded us or succeeded us as out
of
so the story is changing even as we
speak and so some of the variation
across humans may relate to
interbreeding with some of these other
hominid species but in general the way
you told it is correct that if you go
far back far enough we all of us you
know are descended from the same
ancestral group of hominids and that's
amazing in a way a feed of life and yeah
well I go all the way back yes well yes
we can speculate about where life came
from listen the question would then
become is and this is what so many of
the indigenous cultures are are pointing
out is that is our species disconnection
from the origin and how we all come from
that same source is that the reason why
we have so many of the issues in our
civilization today no I wouldn't go that
far
I mean first of all even among other
some of the other animals we discussed
earlier you know so one pod of killer
whales who have identity and cooperation
and friendship and all these qualities
can be rather mean to other pods of
killer whales and you know they're not
humans same with with chimpanzees
chimpanzees groups of chimpanzees have
this just like we do have this sort of
tribalism this sort of in-group bias you
know us versus them and they'll patrol
the perimeter of their turf and they
will kill and eat other chips that they
that they murder so but it is our
highest potential pinnacle state of
being to embody that deepest sense of
empathy for the other that is with their
unique expression artistic expression of
existence on this on this well I would
agree with that spiritual claim but I
would I would dispute
I mean there's a kind of you're sort of
sneaking in a kind of teleology there
where you're imagining that you know
that that is the only or right way my
claim at the beginning was not that
natural selection wanted to make it good
to endow us with these good qualities my
claim is only that these good qualities
counterman the bad news which also
exists and in the claim of the
indigenous would then be something along
the lines of that because the species
has deviated away from this natural
spirit or source of our origins is so
much of the reason why we have many of
the issues that we have in our world and
yeah I think that's I mean that's a
possible explanation I think that I
think that there are ways in which the
worlds we make for ourselves now because
of our capacity for culture which we
innately have the ability to be a
cultural animal is itself a product of
natural selection so we can each fashion
these cultures we can make these
enormous technological civilizations and
I do think that those civilizations
there are aspects of them that can
alienate us from our roots and certainly
feel alienating so for example imagine
for hundreds of thousands of years we
evolved to live in groups where to
encounter strangers might have been
dangerous and to be with people we know
well we were
where evolution shaped us to value that
and feel good about that so to be with
friends it gives us this warm feeling
and so we want to be with our friends
and so the argument would be that
friendship is enhances our survival
being with a group of friends is good
you can hunt prey you can defend
yourself against others so we come to
feel hey it's good to be with friends
because those people who felt it was
good to be with friends and hang out
with friends were more likely to survive
compared to those people who were
indifferent to their breasts of their
friends okay so you can construct that
whole argument about how we have these
these these these warm feelings so now
you take a creature like that and you
put that creature in a modern world in
which we interact with each other not
authentically and face to face as human
beings but in roles like bureaucracies
and you go to meet someone at the DMV
and that person doesn't know you and
treats you imperiously or you move among
strangers on a street for example or you
go to a workplace and you have
superficial inauthentic interactions
with other people all of which are
products of modernity and and those make
a creature like us sense danger we we
find that alienating we find that
inconsistent with our nature we find
that you know discombobulating it we
sense that that is potentially a
dangerous and and unwholesome set of
social interactions and so we crave kind
of authenticity and real face-to-face
interactions so in that regard I would I
would agree with your point yeah
and similarly with the amounts of light
pollution that's in the metropolis as
the children are born without ever
seeing the cosmos the children walking
out of a grocery store exchange of sheet
of paper for the goods instead of
knowing how to grow them from the soil
these are very raw disconnections from
source and from the breaths of air that
sustains a gulps of water that do is I
think such a perfect pertinent point
from the indigenous culture now ok
here's a really good one that I want to
talk about so at least a little bit we
need to talk about this the meme gene
interplay so meaning that the way that
we have now told stories the way that we
have now built tools that have shaped us
we've built cities that have shaped us
this is actually directly from these
artists cities what we were just talking
about how that's shaped us so and the
mimetic evolution cultural evolution is
just moving way faster the devices that
are everywhere now that are shaping us
and the way that we socially interact
way faster than digit slower genetic
pace of evolution how do you see that
interplay between mimetics and genetics
and even people that are choosing to
just be like like in Silicon Valley and
so many other places they're like I need
to climb up the competence hierarchy I'm
not having children for a long time
maybe even not ever I just have to keep
climbing this competence I already I
have to spread these memes these ideas
all eight billion people are my children
my brothers and sisters I will spread
ideas to that rather than having one
child and spreading ideas yeah what are
you about something like that ok well I
can go into directions with that first
of all this whole notion of memes has
gotten far from its original sort of
more narrow meaning which I think
Dawkins was trying to argue for which is
sort of self-replicating idea just like
a gene is a replicator right it's in a
host and it replicates itself
so I think one of the most famous
example of this was the the mean that
killed the infidel so kill individuals
who don't share are your religion that's
a very powerful idea because if the
people don't share your illusion you
kill them and they're fewer of them so
therefore people with your religion that
have the belief kill those that don't
have your religion become more numerous
so so so but memes has now come to me
just sort of ideas that spread you know
from my brain to your brain for example
and and there's a sense in which that's
the case but I'd like to then broaden
that and address more directly your
question which is this notion of
gene-culture co-evolution for which
there's a ton of work being done in labs
around the country Joe Henrik is and can
and lalonde in Scotland there's some and
and Boyd Richardson and there are a lot
of people that are thinking deeply about
about gene-culture co-evolution so the
idea here is is that that human beings
have been endowed with the capacity for
culture we we've also been endowed with
the capacity to accumulate culture so we
don't just distribute information and
ideas laterally across space we also
distribute information across time yeah
which means that we accumulate all of
the knowledge from the past so when you
are born today you are born into a world
in which calculus has been invented
already in hand and animals have been
domesticated you know and someone built
roads a hundred million humans built the
civilization not a hundred billion but
are citing the numbers a billion be you
know 100 billion people before us you
were no no that number can't be run
we're just giving the numbers of five
plus million years of what is a perk
what are we definitely I don't think I
think that I don't know the precise
numbers but I would be stunned if there
had ever gone hundred billion people had
ever been
live I could be right yeah back thank
you it seems very high to me okay but
anyway all those people work sorry but
reduce yet however many they were a lot
of they work hard to produce all the
stuff and we're just born and we
inherited on the day we were born we get
all of this stuff knowledge about the
Stars and about nano fabrication and
about the tides of figuring out
longitudinal latitude and how to build
roads and chisel stone and and milk cows
and you know all of this stuff that
other people had invented and given to
us then we build on that foundation and
create new stuff and transmitted and so
forth so so culture cumulates and
evolves and and people experiment
constantly so by chance occasionally we
discover an innovation and in the book I
talk about for instance the cumulative
culture with respect to arrow poisons
you know how did they how in the Amazon
do they make you know poison darts and
the preparation of kirari for example
which is not easy to do you know over
hundreds of years these people figured
out how to prepare curare in very
specific ways in very specific steps and
it's this capacity for culture that
actually makes us the ascendant species
on the earth we have pathetic bodies our
bodies would be unable to survive in all
these environments and yet we can make
parkas and kayaks and dig wells and we
can live in deserts in the Arctic and
and we transmit that knowledge and it's
that that capacity for culture that
allows us to have a social conquest of
the earth as Neil Wilson says anyway so
all of that is happening that cultural
evolution and in parallel to that we
also continue to evolve as you said at a
somewhat slower pace genetically but the
amazing thing is in the last 30 or 40
years people have begun to understand
how these two parallel systems interact
and my favorite and simplest example of
this is the example of the domestication
of cows so so so humans have an enzyme
in us called lactase that's able to
digest lactose which is the principal
sugar in milk
and all of us have lacked tastes as
babies why because we're suckling in our
mother's breasts and we drink milk and
we need to be able to digest the milk
that our mothers feed us and after we're
weaned we no longer have lactase why cuz
there's no milk in our diet there's no
reason for us to be able to digest milk
in adulthood and yet billions of people
today are able to do that why are they
able to do that well it turns out that
between 3 and 9 thousand years ago human
beings had a cultural innovation which
is they domesticated cattle they figured
out how to breed cattle and feed cattle
and contain cattle and create an animal
that was available to us to eat and to
mill milk and drink the milk
so those members of our ancestors who
lived in a world in which they had
domesticated cattle now suddenly had an
adverse among them who could digest milk
had a survival advantage they had
another source of food and they had a
source of clean hydration when the water
was spoiled
so those individuals who by chance had
mutations that had sort of lactase
persistence into adulthood outperformed
outbred had a Darwinian fitness that was
higher than those that do not and what's
seen when you go and this has been
worked out by Tishkoff and other
scientists when you go when you look in
africa at those populations in the last
three to nine thousand years there's
been as multiple domestication of cattle
and multiple independent evolutions of
the ability to digest lactose that occur
in specific populations but not in
nearby human populations that didn't
domesticate the cattle so here we have
an example of something human-beings
invent in historical time three to nine
thousand years that changes the
environment around them feeds back on
that and acts as a selection pressure
and and changes the trajectory of our
genetic evolution now all these humans
billions of them have lactase
persistence and it's not just cattle
there are many examples of this so it's
quite possible that our invention of
cities in a similar timeframe
is making a smarter those among us that
can live in cities that have brains that
allow us to live in cities may actually
be getting smarter so different kinds of
brains are required to live in cities
let's say then to live in the country
for example so here we have invented
cities and again we're changing that or
a simple example it might be you know
medieval lens grinders invent this I
would have died ten thousand years ago
I'd have been eaten by a lion but now I
can live so I pass on my jeans from
myopia to my children
myopia to my children and so the species
is becoming more myopic because we
invent glasses and indoor rooms it turns
out and books and so forth so anyway
Dean cultural leukemia will also that
you gave this example you you've given
so many of these other examples in your
writing as well where you have these
little subculture pockets that develop
unique skill sets based on their
environments and what they need to do to
survive in those environments and then
that has that gene-culture co-evolution
that's occurring in an aquarium that can
occur and what about taking that all the
way up to today with these claims about
well I want to spread my memes out to
all eight billion people I don't want to
focus on genetics I want to focus on
memes and now I have information
technology so I can spread memes way
faster yes so what do you what well I
think I mean if you're asking is the
Internet changing us I think we won't
know the answer that for a couple
thousand years but I think yes I had to
guess could mosaics be more important
for climbing up competence hierarchies
than genetics now yes yes I think the
capacity to to manipulate information is
hugely important and getting more so but
a simpler example might be Google glass
so let's say Google glass you know has
facial recognition software and can call
up the internet so I'm walking through
down the street and the glass is
detecting everyone I see and pulling up
their biography and then using natural
using artificial intelligence to label
them friend or
so I no longer something that was
crucial for hundreds of thousands of
years in our evolution which is to
detect other people yeah we talked about
that earlier detecting individual
identity and knowing whether they mean
you ill or well we can delegate to a
technology yeah so I no longer need to
be quite a social creature I can just
rely on a technology to recognize other
people and call up their data and tell
me whether they are friendly or or
menial and you know feed into my ears
say this person is your friend you know
his name is Alan treat him well versus
you know this person is a bad guy you
know we find him in the criminal
database you know walk away you know
this kind of thing so um so that that
kind of technology I think is going to
reshape how we interact with each other
but over very long time periods not over
you know the the people you alluded to
who are climbing this pyramid in their
own lifetimes they're they're not gonna
change the species in 50 years and so
these are long horizon things but but
still discernible over historical time
it's it's interesting looking at what
kids 50 years from now will be saying
about what we used as these
technological appendages and how they
affected gene-culture co-evolution yeah
I'm sure I wouldn't say 50 years
necessarily but but there absolutely are
things technologies that we're inventing
now that are changing the fitness
landscape for human beings that are
enhancing the prospects of survival for
some of us and not for others and faster
than ever doing that I would say yes but
it's not just the speed it's like the
impact of selection so for example
elephants are evolving in real time
right now to be tuskless that was a
crazy exam yes so right now in the last
30 years because of human predation and
elephants that doughnut tusks survived
elephants with tusks get killed so but
that's a very powerful selection force
that it was hunters go out and kill
these and not those there's nothing
quite as powerful that's affecting us
right there's not like half the
population is being exterminated because
they have this
these set of features yes and that would
rapidly weed it out so some people
speculate that we'll all be more
religious in the future because one of
the ascendant means right now has to do
with reproduction so educated people
tend to have fewer and non-religious
people and have fewer children than
religious people so so brains that are
endowed with the capacity for religion
tend to be more fecund so in this
historical moment so so you're gonna get
more of them and what are the future
religions that don't necessarily yet
exist that can potentially bring the
entire species together again something
like we all come from the same source we
all come from the same I don't know I
mean I like they know like I like I'm
very partial to the Star Wars religion
you know the Jedi you know these old you
know the notion of a force but I find it
very hard to imagine that human beings
will converge on a single religion that
doesn't seem likely to be is Nicholas
would you say that that this world that
we live on and the entire process of
going from source until here and all
that is is this one big artistic
expression I don't know the answer to
that question what is it I mean my
favorite my favorite my favorite answer
that question is in in Stephen Hawking's
a brief history of time he very
nonchalantly says you know when they're
working he's trying to figure out when
the Big Bang occurred and how he's
solving problems having to do with black
holes and in that mechanical voice of
his he I can't imitate it I wish I could
he says while these discoveries do not
shed light on whether there is or isn't
a creator they do put a constraint on
when he did his creating so you know I I
don't think we can answer those types of
questions with science
I were talking about this refrán I
really hope that science can get to the
point of being able to better poke and
probe at that because then that will be
a more beautiful melding between
spirituality and science in the future
okay I really need to talk about this
subject this is a lot of ways this is
how I see the world our show is called
simulation and in for a variety of
reasons but one of the reasons why and
we mentioned this earlier too is that
it's really cool to think those thought
experiments where you say well would
this same topology of social networks
with humans have evolved if we ran a
simulation of the species again and so
here's this question than to ask and and
you know you kind of do this a little
bit at the human nature lab you called
this thing also you gave an example of
what would be like a forbidden
experiment like what would it be like to
evolve a simulation of a couple of
humans on an island by themselves and
where they didn't have any of the same
endowments that we had like we have from
these hundred billion or however many
people that have made the world so how
would they pick up a language how would
they pick up the tools how would they
look up all these things so speak to the
importance of the work that that is
something that that can reveal more yes
so the the argument is that you know
that if I take a human and or like a
monkey and just feed it and give it
water it'll be boring a little thing
it'll grow up and it'll have an adult
type body that's innate that's like you
know that the the genes shape the
structure and function of the body
now you could starve the animal and get
stunted growth but in a kind of
wholesome environment this is the body
you get because of the genes
well genes don't just shape the
structure and function of our minds I'm
sorry of our bodies they also we're
increasingly discovering shaping the
structure and function of our behaviors
and they don't just do that they also as
our youth shape the structure and
function of our societies there's a kind
of innate kind of society that we are
endowed to make just like there's an
innate kind of body
we're endowed to make and and so the
question is you know how could we prove
that so in a kind of mad scientist
fantasy what we would do is we would
take a group of babies that had like no
cultural learning and we would abandon
them on an island and let them grow up
you know plentiful food and stuff and
and see what kind of society they made
now of course this is unethical and
cruel and could not be done and it's
been called the forbidden experiment you
simulate it well and we do yeah we do
but and so and but this forbidden
experiment there have been times we are
told that very powerful monarchs have
done something similar to that for
different reasons for example Herodotus
writes about a pharaoh santak the first
who wondered what kind of language was
ancestral that is to say what kind of
language was innate and so these
monarchs would contrive to take a babies
and give them to mute shepherds to raise
up in the mountains and then see well
what language did they speak when they
grew up for example in order to
understand like what what language
capacity is innate within us so
obviously we can't do this kind of
experiment so I was trying to figure out
like what would be reasonable proxies
for this and one idea I had was to look
at unintentional groups of people thrown
together unintentionally for instance in
shipwrecks
and between 1500 and 1900 there were
9,000 approximately shipwrecks - such a
cool study during the European
exploration of the world I found 20
shipwrecks that had 19 people that were
isolated for at least two months and the
question is when these people were
thrown on this island and they had to
make a society what kind of society did
they make and what were the qualities of
that society and which of those
qualities was associated with success or
failure did they survive or not so I
found this corpus of 20 shipwrecks these
examples I got all the original
narratives of the survivors with all the
modern archaeological excavations of the
shipwreck sites looking to see did they
work together to build a well or a
signal tower today did they have higher
are heated they have one dwelling or
several dwellings you know for the crew
and the passengers for instance are the
officers and the crew or whatever and to
make a long story short many of these
qualities that we were discussing
earlier is innately fundamental in us
are also seen in these examples but that
wasn't the only type of thing I looked
at I also looked at intentional
communities for instance communes in the
1960s or communitarian movements in the
nineteenth century you know the shakers
for example or the kibbutz --is in
Israel I looked at scientific
settlements so scientists that were
stranded in Antarctica for two
winterover groups of thirty scientists
that lived in this community what kind
of social order did they make for
themselves
Pitcairn for instance or the Shackleton
expedition so many many examples and
then finally in my lab we've developed
the speaking most closely to simulation
we've developed a kind of software
that's integrated with Amazon Mechanical
Turk so we can we in a god-like way can
create temporary artificial societies of
real people and tens of thousands of
people we basically paid small amounts
of money to from Amazon Mechanical Turk
but we've also done this with other
sources of subjects and they can come to
our laboratory and we can in a god-like
we control like engineer the society
they are in to have let's say this
topology a very natural topology of
social interactions or an unnatural
topology and drop them in and say okay
which does better our people when
they're dropped into a natural topology
better able to cooperate yes if they're
dropped into an unnatural topology
no they won't calm or even an even more
communal topology it could cooperation
be even better maybe and we are doing
some new experiments to see if we can
increase cooperation very good question
so we're doing all of that work so we
created artificial societies and across
all those examples unintentional
societies intentional societies
artificial societies again and again we
find that human beings
innately are equipped with certain
capacities to make particular kinds of
social order and furthermore that the
social order is very is good and
universal and then what other ways would
you manipulate the artificial
environments that people are going into
to see if we could you gave the example
of potentially increasing cooperation
what other unique insights would you
would you say you in the lab are most
interested in exploring with tweaking
those environments okay so one of the
things we're very excited about right
now is our research on what we call
hybrid systems of humans and machines so
we're doing lots of experiments in which
we we create systems of people into
which we interspersed some BOTS let's
say and so you then create a hybrid
system of humans and machines that are
interacting on a level playing field and
what we're trying to do in my lab is
develop forms of artificial intelligence
particularly forms so we're not
interested in developing super smart AI
to replace human cognition like alphago
for example that can play go or the
poker playing AI which is unbelievable
no we're not we're not inventing super
smart AI to replace human cognition
we're developing dumb AI to supplement
human interaction so the question is can
we develop machines that when we
intersperse them into humans because the
humans are smart
the machines act like catalysts lowering
the activation energy and facilitating
the interactions or reactions between
humans let me give you some examples so
a very simple example might be alexa or
other kinds of personal assistants
people don't realize that those
assistants are programmed to facilitate
your interaction without assistant and
so that is that assistant for instance
is programmed to be very obedient it
doesn't require you to say please Siri
or please Allah thank you now that stuff
so you then get entrained to behave very
rudely and then you leave here is that
assistant and you go into the real world
and you interact with other humans and
now maybe you're rude mm-hmm so this
machine is changing your interactions
not with it but
oh yeah so we need to think about how we
program these machines to make you will
it's a more polite rather than less
polite yes even more creative or
whatever more deeply pursuing your own
divine or instance all these things for
instance exactly so we need to be
mindful of the fact that as we introduce
these social machines in our midst they
are transforming how we interact not
with them but with each other and this
happens for example with autonomous
vehicles so so right now the concern is
how do we how should the autonomous
vehicles be programmed to maximize the
safety of the people in the car but
actually maybe what we should be
concerned about is how should the
autonomous vehicles be programmed to
optimally modify the human drivers
behavior on the road
so can we program these cars in a way
that changes your driving behavior to
make you less likely to crash into him
it's not about whether you're less
likely to crash into this the driverless
car is about how the driver of this car
changes your your ability to crash into
someone else so we are experimenting in
my lab right now with these types of
ideas hybrid systems of humans and
machines or humans and BOTS online and
we have a whole suite of ideas on ways
to develop and test BOTS to reduce
racism online reduce the problem of fake
news online increase cooperation online
increase sharing of information within
firms and so forth and so on I love how
you have that meta perspective on the
way that we're developing the robots and
AIS and being very aware and vigilant of
the way that we interact with them and
how that's going to influence the way we
interact with each other outside of that
relationship and that's so evident
already with our devices that we have
and our level of aggression or less
empathy when we're typing behind the
word versus looking at yes in the eyes
and yeah it's seeing that yeah yeah
that's okay okay and just a quick
questions that we like asking on the way
out of the show do you think we're in a
simulation
we could be but I don't think we are NY
I just don't think the fabric of the
physical world is consistent with an
entity that could design the universe
but it's unprovable so and then what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world
consciousness and why well because
that's how we are endowed with the
ability to see the world right and to
think about it
I mean absent consciousness I don't I
don't think we would even be we wouldn't
even be able to ask these questions so I
think I mean there are there's a whole
category of things which I'm sure you've
thought about which arise because of
what's known as the phenomenon of
emergence right so holes have properties
not present in the parts the whole is
greater than the sum of its parts and so
the fact that you can take a set of
neurons and interact and connect them in
a particular way and because of that
pattern of connection you give
consciousness is miraculous to me
consciousness is an emergent property of
neuronal tissue and then there's also
the pan site-- kiss ideas of
consciousness is everything is all that
is these are very interesting enzyme
nicolas this has been such a pleasure
talking to you it's been an honor we're
thank you thank you so much that's great
thank you for all of your incredible
work in the space and also thank you
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
and also check out the links in the bio
below check out the links to Nicholas's
pages as well as his lab his Twitter
profile and his newest book the
blueprint the evolutionary origins of a
good society please check that out and
go and share more conversations with
your family your friends your co-workers
people online about the subjects that we
discuss today about our blueprint for
goodness go and share those everyone in
also support the artists entrepreneurs
the spiritual leader is the
organizations around the world that you
believe in support them and help
grow supports simulation our links are
below to our patreon our cryptocurrency
link our PayPal link you can design cool
merchants get paid as well support us
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon that's a wrap thank
you so much for having me that would say